so the problem that we have with
russia's against aggression against
ukraine is that it's not only an
aggression uh against uh another country
uh it's an aggression against the
foundational principles of the
international system multilateralism
something that we both
believe in and invest in the united
nations charter which puts at its heart
the sovereignty and independence of
nations and it was created
in large part to try to after two world
wars to make sure that there wasn't
another one
and the basic principles that it
established were designed to do that
but if we allow a big country to bully a
smaller one
to simply invade it and take its
territory
then it's going to be open season
not just in europe but around the world
and we'll have repercussions here and
repercussions uh everywhere we don't see
conflict anywhere
we did not want the russian aggression
against ukraine we tried
very hard to
diplomatically to ward it off because
that's not how we want to be spending
our time
and similarly
the
reaction now by
by china
with regard to taiwan and the military
actions is taken
allegedly in response to the peaceful
visit of a member of our of our congress
that too
doesn't help things nor does the fact
that
china has said it's ceasing cooperation
with the united states
on dealing with climate change
that's not punishing the united states
that's punishing the entire the entire
world and especially the developing
world